hi you guys i am kade gottlieb and i'm
got mc and this is our glam run filter
[Music]
okay so what does it mean to be the
first trans male
on rupaul's drag race it means so much
to me
that i'm the first trans male to compete
on rupaul's drag race just because
i have always been looking for
[Music]
someone like me in the media and the
fact that i went on my favorite tv show
of all time and was able to be that for
so many people is just mind-blowing to
me to this day and i'm so proud
what have been your key turning points
in your journey of self-expression to
who you are today
i think some of the key turning points
to me were definitely
obviously me coming out it took so
much self love and confidence that i had
to find out of nowhere to be able to
come out to my friends and family and
then i think also
being able to just go on national
television and being as open as i was
and just share my story
it was just i think all these pivotal
moments in my life helped me
be exactly who i am today and i am ready
to grow
even more every single day okay so you
describe yourself as
pansexual what does that mean to you
and how do you feel about labeling
attraction
yes i do identify as pansexual
um to me it just means that i do not
care
about gender at all all i care about is
like a really gorgeous personality
and that's it and labeling attraction
is just not i don't think it's an
important thing i think as we progress
as a community and as a society a
society overall we're just gonna
stop with the labels because like what's
the point of that love is love period so
there's no point in having to like keep
shoving yourself in a box because as
people as human beings were constantly
evolving and growing so why are we gonna
re-label ourselves every time we
discover a new part of ourselves it just
doesn't make sense so
not a huge fan of labels even though i'm
labeling myself every second
apparently
what does pride mean to you oh my gosh
pride is the most important thing in the
world to me i think
um me and asia o'hara were actually
talking about on the bus the other day
on tour we were talking about how
i feel like a lot of the queer community
loves pride so much because it's kind of
just a time where it's like
our whole lives growing up as kids we
might not have
had a space to come and celebrate who we
are we might have had to hide that
as kids or young adults and then when
you're an adult
you get to go to pride and you get to
celebrate pride and you're just gonna
be the person that you've always wanted
to like scream for the rooftops that you
are
and so i think for a lot of us it's just
it's exactly that it's a
true celebration of all the pain and all
the
hard work that we've put into
ourselves and our lives and our journeys
and it's a time to celebrate and
exactly what i said scream from the
rooftops
that we are here and we're not going
anywhere
and it's time to celebrate so prize
everything to me
how do you look after your mental
well-being i actually am like
kind of forget to look after my mental
well-being sometimes but i need to get a
little bit better at but
for me i truly just need one day where i
don't leave bed like maybe
once a month i just need to lay down for
14 hours like full lay down that's how i
need to
recover it's like a full charging an
iphone but it's me
okay so how do you feel about social
media like both the positive
and the negative sides of it i
personally love social media because i
feel like i thrive with my personality
and i love to talk to people
and connect with people so i love being
able to just like
go online and meet new people i also
think it's so important to
share what's going on in the world and
all these different forms of media you
can literally go on and see what's
happening
all around the world which we did not
have access to like that before so
i think social media is just a really
important tool as well as an amazing
fun tool to be able to share your art
and grow as an artist and find
your tribe in the world so it's i'm
obsessed with social media personally
what is the best piece of advice that
you've ever been given
and by whom my favorite piece of advice
i've ever
been given was actually on drag race and
it was when rupaul
said you already got the job you just
have to show up and i
literally took that to heart because i
feel like when i get
a bigger job and start leveling up i
always get so nervous and scared and i'm
like oh my gosh what if i mess up and i
start spiraling with my inner saboteur
but the second she said that and i it
just all clicked to me that i got the
job
for the hard work that i've done in the
past and everyone there wants me to
succeed so i just have to show up and
kill it so
you already got the job you just have to
kill it totally
what is the biggest challenge that you
face on the journey to who you are today
i feel like my biggest challenge on my
journey of life has
kind of just been i feel like something
with my
transition i guess i think just being
able
to find a place where i can go out every
day comfortable with
who i am physically emotionally
spiritually was a
crazy journey for me as a transgender
individual so
i think just figuring all that out and
aligning all my
chakras and spiritual moments together
to be
a happy a genuinely happy individual
took a lot of
work and i'm proud of the work that it
did but it definitely took
a momento to get there and i'm very
proud of who i am today because of it
on the show you realize that being your
most authentic self
is the most important thing how did you
come to that realization
i think i came to the realization that
authenticity is just the most important
thing in the world
through trial and error almost i think
just going out every day and trying to
discover who i am and
where in life i'm comfortable and happy
makes you kind of
go out on the limb a lot and do
try new things all the time and push
yourself out of your comfort zone
and i realized through all these crazy
experiences that i've had that
where i succeed is when i'm not worried
about what anyone else around me is
doing i'm not worried about
what's going on around me at all
actually all i'm worried about is what
energies i'm putting out into the world
and that is when people connect back
with me and when people respond to what
i'm putting out is when i
am 100 me 100 authentic and
not caring what is happening around me
really
okay how has your drag look changed
since being on the show
my drag look i think my drag look has
changed a lot since being on the show
first of all i've refined a lot of
things after seeing myself on tv
every week physically and then i also
think
that i have gotten more comfortable with
my
physical appearance in drag before the
show i was definitely
a little nervous to get a little too
feminine and then
seeing myself on the show try to be more
feminine than i would
normally be comfortable with i was like
oh my god i look gorgeous like this is
so fun and so now i
am definitely down to experiment
and play a little bit more with
femininity
and my overall vibe and i'm i'm super
obsessed with that so get ready for some
more
girly momentos from got no barge yes
who is your lgbtq plus
icon of all time oh my gosh i think
i mean i love a share moment she's not
like
she's not she's just a gay icon so
cher's my
main [ __ ] i love a dolly parton i love
a rupaul i think rupaul really when i
was in high school was the
closest thing that i saw that was kind
of like i remember seeing her on tv and
being like that
is what that's the closest thing to what
i am that i see
this gender bending
crazy thing on tv like pushing gender
stereotypes on national television just
blew my mind so i definitely wouldn't
not be who i am today without rupaul so
i feel like rupaul's a
major one for me as well how are you
going to be celebrating pride month
well i'm actually on tour for all of
pride month i'm on a tour called drive
and drag which is
pretty much the only tour going on
during the pandemic and you literally
drive
up to the stage and it's some of my best
friends in the world
we're all on tour we're having the most
magical amazing time ever
truly when i have to leave the tour for
one second i get sad because
it is just the best vibes it's so much
fun the whole audience has so much fun i
run around and signed shirts so
if you see me on that tour in prime
month you better go because we will kiki
all night it's just like it's
literally the most fun i've ever had in
my life what changes would you like to
see
in the way that the lgbtq plus community
is represented in society
i just want to see so many more stories
being told i think
from what i've seen on drag race my
story opened up a lot of people's minds
and at the end of the day i am
[Music]
you know i'm still a boy we're doing
drag it's just not it's not like the
craziest craziest thing in the world
just people have never heard of it
or seen it before so i'm really excited
to
be able to come up in here and open up
these doors and say
hey guys what we thought was the end-all
be-all
is not there's so many more stories and
i'm so excited to
see drag race see the hollywood see
mainstream media keep pushing those
boundaries along with me
and hear so many more amazing stories
from
trans women who started the drag
movement to
you know just literally you name it
there's every color of the rainbow in
our
gorge rainbow community so i just want
to get as many stories told as possible
what advice would you give to a younger
you
oh um advice to a younger you i would
say
to me right i think i would probably
just say
that you're valid i think i spent so
long
just thinking that i was crazy and that
i just needed to like
relax and there wasn't my transness
wasn't trans enough or
valid enough and so i would just go back
and say what you're feeling is 100 valid
just because you don't
see it out there in the world does not
mean it's not 100 real
and you should just say
it and fight for what you think is
correct because it is
and i think that's a lot of my friends
too they have the exact same story where
they just didn't see who they were
on tv or in the media anywhere and they
couldn't find anyone like
themselves so they just kind of put
themselves on the back burner because of
it and i feel like
that's what we need to keep pushing is
that what you're feeling is 100 correct
just because you don't see it does not
mean it is not real
all right what advice do you have for
young
lgbtq plus kids today
that may be struggling with finding
themselves
for the young lgbtq plus
kids out there today i would just tell
them to
stay strong stay positive no matter how
hard it gets
there is a light at the end of the
tunnel you are going to find
your chosen family out there you're
going to find your tribe and it's going
to be so amazing it's just gonna take a
second so keep pushing you are like i
said 100
valid there's so many people out there
that love you and support you
and make sure you reach out to people
online that you see that you might feel
connected with because they'll talk with
you i'm sure and
you're gonna get through anything you're
a strong [ __ ] and i believe in you
all right gorge thank you so much for
being here it was so
good seeing you and this has been
glamour
unfiltered edition thanks for watching